I don't think anybody that I know knows
that song but I think
I've ever known in my life
no but it's great though it's a great
song it's like one of the biggest two
eggs I think you guys did it justice
chance the rappers got jokes funny
enough to have Kelly Clarkson falling
out of her seat I feel like I'm nailing
it the laugh out loud moment played out
during the voices battle rounds after a
couple of Niall Horan's team members
performed Stevie Nicks and Tom Petty's
stop dragging my heart around
it's not
[Music]
turn
[Applause]
[Music]
when it was time for some coach feedback
chance was honest about his lack of
Music knowledge great stuff that was
awesome man thank you I gotta be honest
I don't know that song at all oh you
don't come on come on no honestly I
don't think I've ever even been around
while that song was playing wow I don't
think anybody that I know knows that
song but I think it's
and that knocked Kelly right out of her
red chair
ever known in my life no
but it's great though it's a great song
it's like one of the biggest two eggs I
think you guys did it justice
yeah
I would say though
wait no stop
he is my favorite coach
it was amazing Kelly a four-time voice
champion and chance a first-time coach
have become buddies since they started
working together well we sit next to
each other we do yeah you have such a
great coach he's gonna be so great for
he's still on fire for you that's going
to be amazing this is my last thing I
was gonna say
please
it's been awesome Kelly's very very
sweet very nice to me
um Blake is here and
and something cool yeah yeah OG coach
and Mr it's my last season on The Voice
Blake Shelton's been welcoming to two
newbies too well for the most part I'm
working with some of the biggest
songwriters and producers on the planet
bragger hey that's just another thing
that she and I have in common I love
[Applause]
on it
good thing that I'm retiring because I
must be Losing My Edge but just because
it's Blake's final go around doesn't
mean Kelly Nile and chance are going
down without a fight get all your
followers you've got a ton of followers
yeah use the followers use the social
media online well I'm not doing the same
thing but social media use your social
media power yeah put me down get take
them down if that's the way to do it if
he wins I am very happy for him because
that is super cool to win on their last
season and he's literally the show and
from its conception but like I'm not
like rooting for him to win I'll be
happy for him if he does but I'm
obviously trying to win myself for like
my team
[Music]
thank you